Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
Orphan Black went a little No Country for
Old Men, Mrs. S is not to be trusted and we
got a bunch more info about the Proletheans’
Plans.
If you’re finding me for the first time,
I’m doing weekly videos for season 2 of
Orphan Black.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
please ask as many questions as you can think
of.
Sometimes it can be hard to follow, but that’s
one of the things that makes it a lot of fun
to talk about.
So careful for spoilers from episode 2 if
you’re not caught up, but let’s start
with top 5 moments and then I’ll do my review.
Trust me, I have just as many questions as
you do.
Here we go.
Number 5 - Cosima Gets Her New Lab
Of all the clones right now, I feel like Cosima
is doing the best job of being a spy or a
double agent.
Alison is just starting to deal with monitor
Donnie, but I think that will mostly be relationship
comedy.
I always get excited for Cosima lab scenes,
because that’s really where you learn a
lot of Clone facts.
Like being fertile or not fertile as is the
case with everyone except Sara.
Did everyone see how much that upset Rachel?
I can’t wait to learn more of her backstory.
It looks like she’ll be working with Cosima
and Delphine, so I’m predicting their lab
scenes in the next couple of episodes will
be my favorite, even if they’re not the
biggest WTFs.
I also thought it was interesting that Rachel
didn’t know Cosima was a lesbian.
And let me know in the comments, what do you
think is actually the most interesting thing
about her?
Number 4 - Donnie is the monitor
Kristian Bruun the actor had this interview
they played during one of the ads where he
talked about how fun it was to play Donnie
as this silly husband character and getting
to watch him do all these new Monitor spy
things was a huge plus for us, the audience,
but not so much for Donnie himself.
Any scene they end up doing inside this new
Mr and Mrs. Smith plotline will be totally
hilarious, but now that Felix is bailing on
Alison and she feels so isolated.
I feel like she’s going to do something
really really crazy.
Like she’ll slowly lose her mind, snap and
do some Helena-Level damage after a few “shopping
trips”.
Remember, she’s the clone with access to
all the drugs and weapons.
I wonder how long it will be before the fireworks
go off.
Number 3 - Orphan Black Road Trip (felix/alison
separation too)
So not only is Felix bailing on Alison, Sarah
and Kira can’t trust Mrs S and the Proletheans
are involved now.
So it’s like all the clones are slowly being
separated, like clone club is on hiatus temporarily.
Based on the teaser it looks like they’re
headed for Cal’s house.
The idea of the Proletheans being sciency
but old timey without a lot of tech kind of
fits thematically with Cal’s character.
So I guess Sarah is just going to spend a
lot of time camping in the woods this season.
It’s super weird too, because the actor
who plays Cal also plays Daario on Game of
Thrones right now and episode air so close
together it’s a little confusing in the
fandom section of my brain.
Number 2 - Mrs. S and the Birdwatchers
I love how much of a badass she was in the
episode.
It seemed like family turning on itself was
a big theme in the episode and turns out the
Proletheans will pay big money to get their
hands on Kira.
It seems like Mrs. S was being truthful when
she said I’ve always been on your side.
But the big asterisk is that she’s not saying
which faction she really belongs too.
It seems like she grew up with the Birdwatchers
but because they double crossed her, I’m
calling Mrs. S like her own rogue faction
in between the Neolutionists and the Proletheans.
It was pretty funny to think of her running
guns when she was Sarah’s age.
Kind of like Sarah selling drugs to make money.
The big takeaway is that Mrs S. knows people
in London that have answers about what’s
going on with Kira’s biology.
It’s like we went from having two factions
to four or more in the span of a few minutes.
I feel like I need to start a flow chart to
keep track of everyone this season.
Somebody feel free to paste a tumblr link
in the comments if you’re actually doing
this.
and my Number 1 moment - The Proletheans want
to breed Helena
Hands down, creepiest moment in the episode.
They didn’t explicitly say it.
But during that whole No Country for Old Men
murder all that talk about Helena conceiving
kind of foreshadowed their creepy cylon plan
to breed her.
It reminds me of that one episode of Battlestar
called “The Farm” where Starbuck get’s
captured by the cylon doctor who tries to
turn her into a baby making machine.
It puts Helena in this really interesting
place, I think she’s going to be one of
my favorite clones this year.
Because she’s super crazy and yeah, she
killed a ton of people including her own clones.
But now she’s being subjected to this creepy
cult, so I feel like we’re going to wind
up empathizing with her.
Let me know if you agree.
Do you think that because of all this crazy
breeding talk, Helena is going to become a
sympathetic character.
She’ll stop being the villain of the show
and start being a victim?
And be sure to let me know what your biggest
question is after this episode?
I’m really wondering who those people in
London are.
One of my favorite funny moments that didn’t
make my top five was Alison’s song, Blood
Buddies.
Let’s hope that one makes the DVD.
Don’t you feel like if Alison doesn’t
get to perform the play full on this season,
they should release it as a bonus feature?
Overall I gave the episode a B plus, I loved
the characters, but some of the pacing felt
uneven.
Especially with everyone going in different
directions.
Sometimes it can get a little confusing when
the different clones switch the energy they
usually bring to scenes.
Like Ailson is normally meant to be a comedian,
and Cosima is the rational brain of the group.
So when Cosima starts being funny in a scene
next to Alison being funny it throws me off
a little.
And that kind of seems where everyone is headed.
Clone Club did get new phones, so I’m expecting
a lot more conference calls.
Since none of them are going to be in physical
proximity for a while.
And eventually, based on what Mrs. S was saying,
Sarah is going to have to go to London eventually.
Let me know if you agree that Sarah will end
up going there this season or if you think
Mrs. S is going to bring someone from there
to Sarah.
It’s like that saying.
Brining Mohammed to the mountain versus bringing
the mountain to mohammed.
We just don’t know who or what the mountain
is in this case.
So next week I’ll post my episode 3 video
after the episode airs.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
And don’t forget, tomorrow is new game of
thrones.
Right now click here for my episode 1 video
and click here to catch up on game of thrones.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!